Nathan is in Colorado my wife thanks for
saving too much money we're gonna be too
rich I'm not gonna be understanding
we're dead free except the house we make
seventy five thousand dollars a year we
only have seven thousand dollars in
savings and I am maxing out a my Roth
IRA
she says I'm being greedy and that we
should be enjoying more of our money how
do I get her on board
without having more in the bank well you
have another issue here that is not a
financial issue there's a breakdown in
value system and in philosophy here okay
the Bible says out of the abundance of
the heart the mouth speaks and if she
accuses you of saving money instead of
her spending money and then her mind
that's called greedy we're going to get
a dictionary out we're gonna have to get
the definition of greedy going because
wanting money in order to spend it is as
greedy as wanting money to save it so
we're playing drama queen here and
there's stuff going on in your marriage
that's way beyond simply whether she
should be able to spend some money or
you should be able to save some money
now I will say that I'm reading between
the lines on this Nathan and while I'm
saying she's a drama queen I think
you're a super tightwad and you don't
have enough in your emergency fund
$7,000 in your emergency fund is not
enough you should not be maxing out your
Roth IRA until you have three to six
months of expenses saved making $75,000
a year my guess is your expenses are
more than $2,000 a month and so you need
more than $7,000 again we'll get you up
ten or twelve thousand in savings for
emergencies and then you do need to
loosen up the budget a little bit
because you have been so spot on you've
done very well financially but the way
you've done that is is you have crunched
down the numbers to nothing to the point
she can't breathe and she's not been
involved in
decision-making you just pretty well
crammed this whole deal down her throat
and her reaction is now she started
calling you names Grady you're just
Grady all because she can't get
something she wants because you've had
the screws tightened down so much and
she did not participate in the
decision-making to tighten the screws
down that much that's what's going on
here see if she was in on the decision
and you were in agreement on the IRS and
the emergency funds and the debt free
except the house and all of that and and
the steps you had taken to get there if
she had been an agreement to all of that
then she wouldn't be calling you greedy
because she wanted to spend some money
but instead she's reacting like a child
and the reason is is you've had the dead
gum screws tightened down and she's not
participating in the decision she has no
voice in these decisions
you give her voice in the decisions and
make her be a grown-up
and go okay we want to retire with
dignity we need to be prepared for
emergencies we are going to stay out of
debt here's our budget now you tell me
where you want to loosen it up our next
goal should be to stop our saving and
investing and filled up our emergency
fund after that if you want to loosen it
up and we don't save for retirement
here's what it's going to cost us and
you talk it through together and you
decide together how we're gonna do this
how can we make some more money
how can we not spend something on
another category so that we can spend it
on this category whatever I don't care
but she's not got any say-so in this
house I can tell by the way you ordered
the question